okay our subject for this evening how to
avoid disappointment
what did i say
and seeing the multitudes
he went up into a mountain
and when he was set
his disciples came unto him
and he opened his mouth and taught them
saying
blessed are the poor in spirit
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven
blessed are they that mourn
for they shall be comforted
blessed are the meek
for they shall inherit the earth
blessed are they which do hunger and
thirst after righteousness
for they shall be filled
blessed are the merciful
for they shall obtain mercy
blessed are the pure in heart
for they shall see god
blessed are the peacemakers
for they shall be called the children of
god
blessed are they which are persecuted
for righteousness sake for theirs is the
kingdom of heaven
blessed are ye
when men shall revile you and persecute
you and shall say all manner of evil
against you falsely for my sake
rejoice
and be exceeding glad for great is your
reward in heaven for so persecutedly the
prophets which were before you
ye are the salt of the earth but if the
salt has lost his saver wherewith shall
it be salted
it is then forth good for nothing but to
be cast out and to be trodden underfoot
of men
ye are the light of the world
a city that is set on a hill cannot be
hid neither do men light a candle and
put it under a bushel but on a candle
stake
and it giveth light unto all that are in
the house
let your light so shine before men
that they may see your good works
and glorify your father
which is in heaven
god is good
and all the time
psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is good
and as we said a few nights ago
when god blesses us
he's good
when he punishes us
he's good when he answers your prayer
come on he's good when he says aloud no
he is good psalm 145 verse 17 the lord
is righteous in all his ways
meaning
god cannot do anything wrong
i was expecting an amen for god
god
cannot do anything
wrong all his ways of judgment
justice
so we thank god for the gift of life
despite the trials and tribulations in
our day-to-day living we are happy to be
alive right now if i'm right say amen
nobody wants to move into a coffin
tonight nobody wants that we're grateful
to god
for life and if you think your life is
hard study the life of jesus
he had no place to live
he had one outfit he had breakfast at
this person's house lunch at that
person's house dinner that person's
house he had no place of his own this
was jesus
so when you think your house isn't big
enough
remember the foxes have holes the birds
of the air have nests
the son of man hath not where to lay his
head
he came that low
that he might reach the lowest of the
law to raise us to the very highest
heights through christ
we are raised higher than even angels
you're very nice people so you're saying
amen
are you following me
listen to me again
through
christ
through the plan of redemption
god will raise us higher
than angels
we just don't understand all that
in the plan of salvation
this life
is this
the life to come
is that
don't put all your focus on this it
makes no sense on any planet
to focus all our energies on this
when this is coming don't miss this for
the sake of this
is anyone with us tonight you are not a
seventh-day adventist you are here for
the first time nice your hand you're not
ah
what's your name
elise
what's the last name
wally how do you spell wally
elise thank you very much for coming
who brought you
well we're glad you've come elise
may the lord bless you you look like a
child of god
nice to see you we'll be here until
saturday night on saturday morning come
again please if you can serious release
may the lord bless you right into his
kingdom
i saw a hand back there my dear sister
what's your name
sherry with an s or c
s how are you sherry
i am fine thanks for asking
where are you from
you're from here all right i'm glad
you're from here come back here tomorrow
night are you following me
sent you from here come back here
tomorrow night let the church be amen
jerry thanks for coming god bless you
may the lord grant you the desires of
your heart and bless you so much you
become a blessing to other people that's
my prayer for you and for at least is
there anyone else you are not a
seventh-day adventist you are here for
the first time
all right what's your name my good
brother
tim is a good man there's a tim in the
bible timothy tim where are you from
delaware that's not terribly far away is
it
wasn't what's the town called
middletown
all right god bless everyone in
middletown tim thank you very much for
coming may the lord place a hand of
mercy upon you and never remove it say
amen for tim
all right and for sherry
and for sure
and for elise
and for
jesus all right no look as though you
you're sleeping with your eyes open all
right
okay our subject for this evening how to
avoid disappointment
what did i say
[Music]
before i get into that what's the first
request i always make of you
make sure it doesn't ring in the
presence of a holy god
pretend you're in a courtroom
you know how to behave in a courtroom i
know you do
you don't want to spend a vacation at
the government's expense so you know how
to behave in a courtroom so remember
we're in the presence of the judge of
all the earth so give him the reference
he deserves and you've been doing that
god bless you favor number two while i'm
speaking pray for me and say lord put
your words in that man's mouth my words
cannot save you the words of christ will
change your life the words of christ
will heal you the words of christ will
fix a broken family because the words of
christ created heaven and earth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth those are the
words i desire to speak and favor number
three think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 what does the first part of
that verse say
come now let us reason together set the
lord and i've told you before god is a
reasonable god
the devil is not reasonable
god
is reasonable
god is a nice person
i like god amen you know we all love god
but i like god are you following me he's
a nice person
ah i will bless the lord at all times
his prayer shall continually be in my
mouth my soul shall make her boast in
the lord the humble shall hear thereof
and be glad oh magnify the lord with me
and let us exalt his name together i
like god let me tell you something about
god quickly is 14 after 7 i'll release
you before eight
god made seven days am i right
how many did he give you
don't take long how many did he give you
how many did he keep
one isn't that a nice god
god says if you have a hundred dollars
how much belongs to me
ten percent he could have said give me
ninety you live on ten
isn't god nice
god made all the trees god told adam all
of those trees are yours leave this one
alone
ah you don't like god
come on say a man for god
let me give a testimony about god in my
life
god has never done me anything
wrong never
all my problems
i have brought
on myself
all my blessings
have come from god
and i'll go to my grave declaring that
god
is a good god
he has never done me
anything wrong
let us pray to this god now father
we come before you in the name of jesus
who is as divine as you are
we thank you father for your stubborn
love
we thank you thank god that your love is
so elastic it stretches around the
universe several times
and right around us
as we bow in your holy presence father
if we have sinned against you forgive us
dear god we are flesh we are weak we are
dust we're made of dirt and so we fall
but we thank you for divine power that
sustains dirt now god cleanse us in the
blood of your son
grant to me your spirit of truth that
the words i speak may be words from your
throne of glory that indeed my words may
be your words
father let your spirit direct my mind
and my mouth a special blessing on all
our visitors who came tonight touched
them very very personally god and may
they always remember their fellowship
with us this night if anyone listening
to me in person or online has contracted
covet 19 in the name of jesus the great
physician heal those persons father hear
them completely to god i'm not
commanding you father i am asking you
because you're merciful bless the
government of this country and all
countries falling online please god take
full charge of me as i try to speak for
you in jesus name i pray let god's
people say amen and amen our subject how
to avoid
disappointment
go with me to job chapter 38 we'll read
from verse 1.
the book of job written by whom
moses very good yes
job chapter 1
not chapter 38 sorry we'll read from
verse
1.
this is god speaking to job
job and his three friends have been
talking back and forth for chapter upon
chapter upon chapter
now it is god's turn to speak
job 38
reading from verse 1 i read from the
king james version of the bible
who is this
that darkness counsel
by words with with not by wisdom by
words without wisdom
gird up now thy loins like a man
for i will demand of thee and answer
thou me now goddess about ask job dozens
of questions by the way not one of which
he could answer
and the questions go from 38 to 40 and
perhaps beyond not one question job
could answer
where was that
when i laid the foundations of the earth
declare if thou has understanding
god tells job
when i said let there be light
when i said let the waters under the
heavens be gathered together unto one
place when i made the mountains and made
a sea and made of fish and made the
birds and made the land animals i made
it freeze where were you
god is putting job in his place
where was that when i laid the
foundations of the earth declare if thou
has understanding who hath laid the
measures thereof if thou knowest or who
has stretched the line upon it whereupon
at a foundation thereof fastened or who
laid the cornerstone thereof when the
morning stars signed together and all
the sons of god shouted for joy god
wants job to answer him when i created
where were you he did not exist
let me tell you something about god
god wants us to come to him
but not to cometh in his face
amen
those are two different things
come to god
don't get up in god's face
you know how we are someone gets up in
your face you tell the person back up
oh i'll back you up are you following me
i'll back you up and down don't get up
in my face now god tells us the same
thing don't get up in my face
but come to me
lucifer got up in the face of god
i will be like the most high and god had
to kick him out of heaven harsh word to
use he was thrown out revelation 12
verse nine isaiah 14 verse 15 he got up
in the face of god god wants us close to
him that's why in christ we sit on the
right hand of god but do not get up into
god's face
always remember who you are i must
always remember who i am when god looked
at adam god said dust
and adam was dust before he sinned
he was dust after he sinned we are dust
when god came down to talk to abraham
about the destruction of sodom and
gomorrah in genesis 18 abraham said who
am i
to talk to god this way i am dust and
ashes because abraham was negotiating
with god for despairing of sodom and
gomorrah because he had a nephew there
primary reason he said how can i talk to
god like this i am dust
let's learn something else about god you
know but let's say in job 38 god
but god has a sense of humor irony verse
god talks to job nurse thou it because
that was then born or because the
numbers of thy years are great god will
say were you there because you've lived
so long
were you alive then
are you so old you know what i created
he is putting job as i said earlier
in his place let's learn something about
god
go to genesis 14.
our subject how to avoid disappointment
well let's not go to genesis 14 yet
let's go to acts
17.
we read from verse 22
our subject how to avoid disappointment
and for those of you online wherever you
are god bless you
thank you for joining with us
and if you're watching this as the
recorded version god bless you as well
do you have the book of acts chapter 17.
you read from verse 22
then paul stood in the midst of mars
hill and said
ye men of athens
i perceive that in all things you're too
superstitious
for as i passed by and beheld your
devotions
i found an altar with this inscription
to the unknown god
whom therefore ye ignorantly worship him
declare i unto you
god that made the world and all things
therein read the next word for me seeing
that he's what lord of heaven and earth
he is lord of everywhere
god that made the world and all things
therein seeing he is lord of heaven and
earth dwelleth not in temples made with
hands
neither is worship with men's hands as
though he needed anything seeing he
giveth for all life and breath and all
things
let's pause
let's look at verse 25 again in the
context of our subject how to avoid
disappointment
neither is
worship with men's hands as though he
needed anything
in other words god does not need my help
to exist
god does not need my help to breathe if
he breathes god is life
somebody say amen god himself
is life are you with me hebrews 2 14
tells us the devil is the power of death
god is life that's why he's frequently
called the living god
he does not need something from us
when moses said
behold when i come unto the children of
israel and shall say unto them the god
of your fathers have sent me unto you
and they shall say to me what is his
name what shall i say to them genesis
exodus 3 verse 13 god said i am that i
am i am the
self-existent one
and i need to show pharaoh that while he
is dependent i am not
ah you're not with me it's my fault
let me try again
there was a time
when nothing and no one existed except
god
the bible teaches us and we cannot fully
understand it god has always finished my
words been there before you were born
then how does god need you
god existed before fruit trees
so what does god doesn't need
he doesn't need food
god existed before he made the
atmosphere he does not need oxygen
understand me clearly
god is self-existent
he is not dependent on me for life but
the reverse
functions in my life i
am dependent upon
god and we have to likely say so are you
now let us go to uh
genesis 18
14 sorry 14.
i mentioned it earlier and then i
redirected you to acts 17. let's go to
genesis 14. let's read from 18. this is
melchizedek speaking to abraham
and the priesthood of christ is based on
melchizedek
because we have no knowledge of
melchizedek's
parenthood or his beginning or his
ending and christ has no beginning or
ending but melchizedek was a real person
but he symbolizes the priesthood of
christ
genesis 14 reading from verse 18 let me
pray again father as i continue restrain
me and remind me my presence in this
pulpit is for your glory help me to do
that i pray in jesus name amen
and melchizedek king of salem brought
forth bread and wine and he was the
priest of the most high god
and he blessed him and said read with me
blessed be abram of the most high god
read the next two words the possessor of
heaven and earth stop
what does melchizedek call god
it's right there
what does he call it
the possessor come on of heaven
and earth
let's look at verse 21 or verse 22
abraham said to the king of sodom i lift
up my hand unto the lord the most high
god keep reading
the possessor of heaven and earth
god
is the rightful owner of heaven and
earth
if you agree say amen
not you
the united states belongs to
god
that's why the bible says the most high
ruleth in the kingdoms of men the
the butt stops at god's desk not by them
but we ought to pray for the leaders are
you with me
the butt stops at god's dest not
vladimir putin now if you're christian
you understand that you can live a quiet
life
because you know
the butt stops on the desk of your god
amen
and god's number one priority on this
earth is his people amen
through whom he advances the gospel
and so we have nothing to fear when
christ stood before pilate pilate said
whence art thou the bible says jesus
gave him no answer
pilate said speakest thou not unto me
nurse thou not that i have power to
crucify thee and i have power to release
thee jesus answered him thou couldst
have no power at all against me except
it were given thee from above my father
has allowed you
amen
allowed nebuchadnezzar into power
are you not listening
you're not with me
god allowed nebuchadnezzar into power
and actually called nebuchadnezzar my
servant yes yes
and told the israelites put your neck
under his rule
until such a time as i decide to get you
up
no matter what your circumstance if you
are a child of god remember the highest
authority in your life is god but be
faithful to him
what have we learned so far
god is in control what else have we
learned tonight
he owns
heaven
and earth and that is no joke what else
have we learned tonight
he has always been
he is
self-existent he is not dependent on us
for his existence and that's a humbling
reality we need to swallow every day god
is not dependent on us we're dependent
on him this is the principle of the
sabbath by the way
the sabbath principle is that creation
depends on the creator not the other way
around amen
so god says every six days stop every
seventh day stop working
stop acting as if you are providing your
own living
did you hear what i said
stop acting as if you are sustaining
yourself and remember i made you i gave
you life i caused the trees to bloom i'm
the one who keeps you breathing i am the
one who keeps you breathing at night
when you have no consciousness i am the
one who say the angels to keep you from
accidents
one day of the week without distraction
from work remember you are dependent
upon me
i am not dependent upon you
amen
let's go to first chronicles 29 it's
7 30 i'll release you before 8 please
don't worry
have i kept my word so far this week yes
all right i'm trying to god always keeps
his word i'm trying to keep in mind i
don't always keep mine but don't tell
anyone
first corinthians 29
let's read from not corinthians sorry
chronicles
thank you my brother chronicles first
chronicles 29 we'll read from verse 11
when you read the bible read
microscopically read as if god is
talking to you that's his voice
do you have first chronicles yeah 29
verse 11
a couple of you still looking i'll give
you a couple seconds
to find it
so we can read together
chapter 29 reading from verse 11 listen
to the words as you read them thine o
lord is the greatness
and the power
and the glory and the victory and the
majesty
read with me now for all that is where
in the heaven come on and in the earth
is thine thing is the kingdom oh lord
and thou art exalted
as head
above all
above how much
next verse both riches and honor cometh
they and the ringest over all and in thy
hand is power and might and in thine
hand it is to make great and to give
strength unto all now therefore our god
we thank thee and praise thy glorious
name listen to verse 14 as david speaks
but who am i
and what is my people that we should be
able to offer so willingly after this
sword finish that verse
for all things come of thee
and of thy known
have we given thee
you read the words let's focus on the
last statement all things come of thee
of course that doesn't include sin they
come from us
of thine own
have we given thee
the very breath you and i breathe now
is from god amen this is no joke
your vision
belongs to god
your physical mobility belongs to god
your mental clarity to understand me
belongs to god
all things
come of thee
if that is the case
that god is not dependent on us
but we are dependent on him let me ask
you this let me pray first father as i
continue the lord strengthen me for your
glory and the blessing of your people in
jesus name i pray amen
here's god
here we are
who owes whom
we are god
let me phrase the question differently
who is indebted to whom
we are indebted to god
in other words god owes me
nothing
what's our subject
how to avoid discipline someone wrote me
several weeks ago
i'm disappointed in god
how can you be disappointed as someone
who keeps you alive i am disappointed in
god
i prayed for this and he didn't give me
and i asked for that and he didn't give
me and i asked for this i'm leaving him
oh my god yes almighty
now let me tell you something the bible
has the bible is a black and white book
and that's not a racial statement it
simply means it's christ or satan are
you with me
are you with me
when you leave god finish my words
make it a little harsher when you leave
god
you're going to satan
[Music]
when you leave god you have one other
option sin yes
there's heaven or
there's no middle ground you're a sheep
or a
goat you're a wheat or a tear
you're saved or you
it is jesus or satan
and so the person said i'm leaving god
or the person was disappointed in god
because the person thought god owed that
person something
someone wrote me
a while ago
i have kept myself sexually pure
why does god give me a husband
god isn't all your husband
are you following me
or white he doesn't
we haven't we set ourselves up for
disappointment by having all these
expectations of god in a sense that we
have demands on god i have lived a
sexually pure life you owe me a husband
have returned a tithe you owe me a big
house
have been a vegetarian you owe me
perfect health
you can't obligate god
we
are obligated to god are you with me
no i may give the impression that god is
a harsh god he is not a harsh god let me
say this very clearly how much does god
owe us tell me nothing but how much does
he want to give us
we're besides and that's ours but he
wants that too
to put it on his
son behold the lamb of god that what
taketh away the greek word to carry
[Music]
my brothers and sisters
god owes you
and me
precisely
nothing
he wants to give us precisely everything
amen
but we have to understand our
relationship with god
let me tell you something i said earlier
we are still dust how can god be
obligated to dirt
when god existed before dirt existed are
you following me we must come to god in
humility father you owe me
nothing
but can you be merciful
will you be merciful that god
i realize you owe me nothing will god
lust to be merciful micah chapter 7
verse 18 who is a god like unto thee
that pardon us iniquity and passive by
the transgression of the remnant of his
heritage he retaineth not his anger
forever because he delighted god loves
to give people a break
give me a break god loves to do it
because he's god
but as i said earlier
come to god but don't get up in god's
face
because he will put you down
nebuchadnezzar got up in god's face
he said is not this great babylon that i
have built god said what
what
the bible says the words have scarcely
fell from his lips
when the lord struck him
and he fell down lived like an animal
for seven years
he wrote you see there's a chapter in
the bible written by nebuchadnezzar
that's daniel chapter four
he wrote that chapter
are you with me
that's a little freebie he wrote that
chapter
he said when i lift up mine eyes and
acknowledge god then my reason returned
and god restored the kingdom uh god is a
good girl come on say amen god gave him
back the kingdom
after he learned do not get up in god's
face
get close to god in his muslim don't get
up in his face
god owes me come on
nothing but through christ he has
actually given me everything
why do i say that
let me pray again then i'll show it to
you from the bible god in heaven
continue to be with me
to slow down and take it easy i pray in
jesus name
amen go to colossians 1.
who's the first person to find
colossians who's the fastest person
in this congregation and on what side
will that person be sitting colossians
1.
okay ah dr jeremy blessings upon you
okay jeremy had it first god blessed
prophet jeremiah all right
let's read from verse 16.
you have that
as usual nobody answered the preacher do
you have that yeah okay
well the weekend is almost over you'll
be spared from all your suffering my
august asking you to talk back to me
let's read from verse 16 of colossians
1. are you there read with me for my
hymn
were all things created that are in
heaven and that are in earth visible and
invisible whether they be thrones or
dominions or principalities or powers
all things were created by him now the
next few words
and for him
who is this him tell me quickly jesus
christ now let's go to john 17.
we read from verse 9
our subject
how to avoid disappointment
john 17
jesus christ is praying to his father
the disciples are listening let us also
listen as we read
john 17 reading from verse 9 if you have
that same amen amen what does the bible
say i pray for them come on i pray not
for the world but for them which thou
has given me for they are thine and all
mine are thy come on enzyme are mine
everything the father has finished my
words
belongs to jesus
now listen to john 3 16 for god so loved
the world that he gave home the one who
possesses heaven
and earth amen
now
when you have jesus
what do you have
everything
and he releases it as he sees you have
what
need
when you have christ
you have everything
he releases it
according to our
needs let's go to john
1 6.
it's uh 20 minutes to 8. i'll release
you before 8.
don't worry
i hope you had a good day at work today
we have a sister who's ready for
translation
john 6 16 let's read from verse 13 are
you there
how be it when he the spirit of truth is
come he will guide you into all truth
for he shall not speak of himself but
whatsoever he shall hear
that shall he speak and he will show you
things to come he shall do up glorify me
for he shall
shall receive of mine and shall show it
unto you read verse 15 carefully all
things come on
that the father hath come on
are mine
so jesus who is represented by the holy
spirit and us
he is in charge of all that jesus has
[Music]
and he takes from that storehouse and
gives to us as we have need not just the
gifts of the spirit he gives us
everything we need whether his health
whatever he gives it now i say to you
again when god gave christ he gave the
possessor of heaven and earth but we
need to live with the consciousness god
doesn't owe me i owe him amen
and so i live for god's glory
i speak with the consciousness i ought
to glorify god
when i dress i think of the glory of god
when i eat i think of the glory of god
when i did i think of the glory of god
why because i owe god
as verily as he gave me everything when
he give christ the decent response from
me is to give god everything of my life
here i am
when i have demands on god i set myself
up for disappointment and god will see
to it i am disappointed in order to
teach me a lesson
the only thing god is obligated to
is this
because he cannot
lie
let me say it again god is obligated to
keep his word amen he's not obligated to
me
now
if i'm smart
i will take the thing god is obligated
to
are you with me
and put it in here
ah
yeah so when god fulfills his obligation
to this where is it fulfilled
amen
thank you i needed that
god is obligated to thus saith the lord
but thus saith the lord in here
so when god fulfills his obligation to
his word the fulfillment would occur
within
how to avoid disappointment
do not approach god as though he is
obligated to you
approach god as though you are indebted
to him
come close to god
don't get up into god's face
god loves you
he does but he's still god
as i told you before when adam was made
he was made of dust when adam stood in
his perfection he was still dust when he
sinned he was the same dust with a
different character
and god told him thus the what psalm 103
verse 14 he knows our frame he remembers
that we are dust
dust cannot hold god under some kind of
obligation
and so tonight
i want you to thank god for his goodness
to you individually
thank god for life
thank god for a roof even if it leaks a
little bit thank god when you turn on
the tap the water flows thank god when
you throw the switch the light comes on
the lord has taken me all over the world
and i've been in places where you throw
the switch and nothing happens
you turn on the tap nothing happens
you want water you walk seven miles get
it from muddy river bring it home boil
it wait for it to cool then you drink it
thank god that despite all the problems
we have in this country it is still a
stable country thank god you call the
fire department they come thank god you
call the police they show up thank god
you call the energy department they come
and restore the light thank god for the
blessing and above all thank god for
jesus
thank god you still enjoy freedom of
worship thank god for the medical system
thank god thank god thank god amen
if you may live our life should be an
uninterrupted symphony of thanks
i often tell my congregations
you cannot do this without god
if you study physiology for a medical
doctor you cannot do because there are
certain processes that take place for
muscles to contract for you to do this
you need god to do this
you see this eyebrow i raise it
on
come on
without god i cannot do that
[Music]
what does the bible say in him
we live come on and move come on and
have our being does not owe me anything
talk to me
do we do does he want to give us
everything yes do we all got everything
yes
how to avoid
disappointment don't put god under
obligation
don't put god under obligation
because god is not indebted to dust
but he loves his creation
to such a degree his son became like us
he took the same dust
live like us
that he may take us all the way up past
the original adam past the angels and
place us right on the throne of the
father in jesus did you hear me
adam was not seated next to god
the angel gabriel is not seated next to
god jesus is and in him you and i are
seated right next to god
we oh god
that's why the angels cry day and night
holy holy holy they can never stop
saying holy because they are also
indebted to god for life
because god created angels
how many will stay with me tonight
father
thank you for opening my eyes help me
god to give all of my life to you i owe
you that can i see your hand ah
stand up with me let's pray
some of you who have been coming you
ought to make decisions about
recommitting your life to god in the
sense of baptism maybe re-baptism that's
a decision you have to make as the world
has been moving in you brand new start
with god as bad eyes closed father in
heaven we thank you so much for this
teaching
the great god of heaven and earth owes
us nothing but through your son you have
given us
everything de god
through the plan of salvation and your
son is the plan of salvation
you desire to raise us to a position
higher than angels
to a position higher than adam occupied
before he sent the god help us in all
that we do to live our lives of the
consciousness i o god and i can never
repay but i recommit my life to him
every day i oh god i'm indebted to god i
thank god
father
forgive us for our arrogance forgive us
for demanding this and that of you their
father forgive us god
dirk does that kind of thing
grant us the humility of jesus
that we may live with the consciousness
that while you owe us nothing
you desire to give us everything and you
have in jesus father
let us change the way we think
and live with the consciousness that our
lives should be an uninterrupted
expression of thanks to you
as we travel home
let's thank you for the cars
let's thank you for paved roads let's
thank you for an organized community
let's thank you thank god for all your
blessings bring us back tomorrow father
thank you for giving us everything in
jesus
in his name we pray let god's grateful
people say amen and amen god bless you
pastor
you may be seated
[Music]
do
you